this year was I mean every year seems
like it's really good for people who
play games on PC PC gamers as it were I
myself have become increasingly into pc
games but a lot of things happened this
year tell us like it seems more
cost-effective than ever to own a pc and
play games on if i'm not mistaken can
you talk about that a little bit with
like new graphics cards new kind of like
I don't know customizable pc options
yeah for any talk about Hardware the pc
hardware is the graphics cards cpus like
SSDs have been about the same price with
every iteration but the boost you get
and performance from the previous
generation is like it's getting better
and better and better so especially if
you're because most people are still
gaming on 1080p so I mean if you're
going to be gaming in 1080p and you have
like a 1070 you're going to be able to
max out everything pretty much I mean
The Witcher 3 if you go back to last
year looks great and runs well a lot of
games in 2016 have we can get into this
later but some performance problems but
the games that do run well you can max
that out even I'm playing doom 3 which
came out this year I'm still on a 970
and I'm maxing that out and it runs
incredibly well so if you go to 1440p or
if you even want to try 4k with with
hardware and graphics cards that came
out this year it's possible so and
that's that's bright the future is
bright for PC hardware and you know ty
16 is a showcase of that yeah I remember
like midway through this year maybe when
what were the Dover the graphics cards I
got an ounce we're like holy [ __ ] that
price for that was that the GTX when
that 1060 was the first one I was like
shocking than Ted I think 1070 was
probably the like the boldest 850 and
now the the 1070 MSRP was around 400 but
it was outperforming the 980 TI right
the SuperDuper dope ass so like previous
generation it also seems like a year
when people who might have been on the
cusp of like I don't know how to build a
pc I don't know what I need myself I
don't I don't I'm not that knowledgeable
when it comes to stuff but this is the
year I actually started looking into it
it felt much more like it was even more
accessible because it's not the most
accessible platform at all that's why
consoles are appealing to some
people you have what you have I think
it's got butterworth once use the like a
metaphor like a console is kind of an
apartment you rent and like when you get
a PC it's more of a house if you own it
but it also you have to take care of it
a lot more and your landlords not gonna
maintain it for you I think it was Scott
that sounds like a Scott metaphor and it
works because I don't actually have to
like what the console this is obvious I
don't have to worry about all that stuff
but this year was the one right first
start approaching it actually being like
oh I can get into this and that's what
like those announcements and everything
and like speaking to you speaking of
Peters being a Jimmy it just seems like
it's easier than ever to build a pc
that's like right for me yeah especially
with tools like PC part picker um it's
very in everyone talking on like PC
gaming centric forums it's they it boils
down to just picking out the parts and
then building your pc is like playing
with Lego blocks essentially you just
put it into place you boot it up you
might have a problem like Peter had
earlier bless my power supply died yeah
hail fall to my own hey it happens man I
tell you to do but I'm yeah it's a
reality you have to face sometimes these
things will kick the bucket because you
are taking components from all manner of
manufacturers and it's a lot of
variables some things might go wrong
yeah it's tough to look back over the
past year and just say this was
consigned this year because it always
seems like developers have trouble every
once in a while porting games to pc i
mean last year i think the biggest one
that stood out was Arkham Knight because
it was so vastly different a PC it was
broken for a while and I remember like
people like had to like specifically
review it on PC because it was so bad
but there were a few bad ports this year
and you know it's tough again the point
that out because it's like a
case-by-case basis like you don't I
don't I'm not a developer I don't know
everything that goes into like
considering all the hardware that these
games have to run on and what not and
what like the specs would be whereas
again the console set we like we looked
at mafia 3 was kind of not performing
crazy well in pc Dishonored 2 for a
really recent one i think it's still has
an ongoing problems when we're talking
about that as opposed to its performance
on xbox one and ps4 but i believe in the
like the report card that you're working
on you mentioned a few questionable
ports can you talk about that yeah so
you mentioned Dishonored 2 and mafia 3
the thing though is that it's it's
frustrating for peace
gamers like I'm gonna drop this money on
a computer and I wanted to run well and
you get that for the most part but when
high-profile games like dishonored tuned
especially I know rob was talking about
how he has like a decked-out computer
and he's having trouble with frame drops
and the thing with with that is that
they're inexplicable when they happen
and like you'll be in a certain space
and you'll be getting a good 60 Plus and
then you'll be turning to another space
that isn't that graphically different
and then you'll drop to like 40 or 30
and it's like while why did that happen
and it's it's tough to figure out so you
have to wait for you know post-release
patches for them to figure that kind of
stuff out and when you compare it to
consoles it's like on consoles you're
going to get like 30 and some framedrops
maybe and but on pc when you're when
you're bouncing between 60 plus and then
down to 40 and back to 60 plus and back
to 40 and 30 it's it's jarring when you
play it so it's like when i'm on the
muni and like the bus drivers like stop
and go stop and go like that that drugs
you off and that's kind of like how it
is with performance issues in these
games right so once I mean you can only
hope for patch that will help that sort
of problem so I make the game a little
bit more playable so it's it happens
2016 there was a lot of instances of
that and I hope that 2017 would be
better but I don't know it's still the
case where we see like when a new big
game comes out for PC there have to be
new drivers issued yeah you know I mean
like what a weird relationship for the
technology and software to have sure it
is frustrating is I mean like it seems
like a lot of times pc gamers kind of
the release date for the game is you
know like december sixth but for pc
players it's really like december 21st
or something I don't know yeah for
instance it's unfortunate because they
have to just keep waiting out and like
reading developer blog post where I'm
sure the developers are trying to figure
out just as hard I don't know what goes
on behind the scene you know that's
unfortunate oh but uh I don't know I do
want to get into the soft water because
there were a lot of good pc games like
pc focus or just like pc games that were
like also on consoles um the first one I
want to talk about as one of my favorite
games of the year and it is on ps4 and
xbox one but it's also like home is on
PC or at least I like probably so over
watch I think you know we've been
playing this you know early access
before it released on PC for a while pc
is where all these like you know that's
where I go for like the halloween events
in the Christmas events and whatnot and
you know it's as a traditional shooter
player i prefer mouse and keyboard and
controller overwatch like blizzard
nailed it again you know they step into
a new genre and they just kind of figure
out what makes it tick and they put
their own take on it and you know this
is I think it's the best hero shooter
there is for like you know like a
sub-genre whatever you want to call it
that has exploded in recent months and
years I don't know you big overwatch
player yeah I play a lot of overwatch I
had it for ps4 and PC because a lot of
my homies play on ps4 but it's like you
said it's home is on the PC because of
how fast and how precise you have to be
with certain characters it works well on
console because of the abilities adapt
well to a controller but like the
competitive play like if you're serious
about competition especially when
Blizzard and overwatch are trying to
establish like the overwatch league for
you make it an easy like a legit eSport
with like regions and cities and yeah
that sounds so cool to me it's like a
fan of traditional sports that just is
really appealing to me idea super into
like I don't want to make up at mascot
the San Francisco Slayers we're done
throwing up let's get back anyway
starting around food no no it's all good
man but layin but yeah but yeah the
overwatch League it's gonna take over on
pc which is because like the level of
play is much higher and that's the type
of game that you wanted to play on pc
yeah i mean like a another huge year for
just for access in general two of my
favorite franchises civ six came out
scott bar with review it gave it a nine
out of 10 says it's it's one of the best
like you know like these games are
changed with their expansions five after
gods and kings and brave new world
became what civ5 could have been and
like it's perfect like it's perfected
vision version once those released sip
six scott like called and i agree the
best initial release in this series ever
you know like a lot of people are giving
it [ __ ] for being like cartoony looking
and kind of like they were trying make
it more accessible i don't think that's
a case i think like it by expanding
these cities you can go you can go for
hours and we've done this before into
like what has changed but i don't know
if we're like just
next numbered entering the civ series
one of my favorites and I I played a lot
of it I want to play more but I was too
busy playing another Firaxis game which
we can get into but yes if six oh no did
you guys get the chance to play this
because this is like it released kind of
right before that huge rush of like
battlefield one titanfall 2callofduty
everything that fall released and it was
kind of right before that unfortunately
so I don't think people get to spend as
much time with it I know if you guys
devoted too much time to step 6 I
literally installed it on my pc this
morning so I can play it before we start
to ring it yeah michael g chance yeah I
played a little bit of suit I played
more sip 5 than I did six but I
understand how six plays into though the
series of civilization and how it's a
much more complete package and I think
also if we're going to keep talking
about 4 axis like XCOM 2 I think it's a
bigger step for the excom series then
sip 6 was for the civilization series
not to say that they're either one's
better than the other because they're
both like two separate teams inside for
axis you know like Jake song riding it
back tom and then you know like in this
case at beach just different people
rotating through but yeah same studio
but they they was on point this year
yeah I wish you hadn't got brought up
cuz I can talk about it forever but X
come to that was said you airy feel
crazy long but now it's on you know like
consoles as well but on pc i mean the
ease of use there were definitely
technical hiccups but i think Firaxis
figured out exactly not just what made
xcom enemy unknown great but how they
could figure like make it you know a
legit sequel that doesn't just like push
what enemy Unknown did but actually do
new things that make you think about
that formula in a way that like that
layered you know RTS and then there's
the turn base and then there's the RPG
elements of the individual characters
just those three layers interacting with
each other I this was one of my favorite
games here it's what my favorite games
on PC ever I think and it's this game is
unreal i think if you have a PC or if
you have consoles now you should play
this and try it out yeah XCOM 2 i'm i
was a big fan of ex-con when I was like
a little kid I watched my brother play
it and that was like super dope boy that
was my entrance into like strategy games
yeah so when they made a research asst
with any me unknown in 2012 oh this is
sure this is great and then so but XCOM
2 takes it a step further in
I think that I always felt like I was on
my toes like you have to deal with
failure we were talking about that
yesterday in XCOM 2 like you're going to
fail at some point in some way and you
have to move on and learn from that and
it does a good cuz then a lot of games
modern games where you know if you die
you just go back to whatever checkpoint
you're in and continue on but like XCOM
2 like the consequences of failure are
very there you feel them in XCOM 2 and
you learn from that and i think that you
know not that maybe more games should do
that but if they do do that like kind of
like almost dark souls esque yep yeah
that's that that is the comparison I
actually think this makes failure more
meaningful than dark souls yeah that's
probably a controversial but anyway uh
world of warcraft Legion another big
expansion that game people are still
playing it after how many years 2 l's
230 yeah I think you're closer it was
good it sounds like they had a new class
the demon hunter courtesy of diablo 3 i
belief or just diablo blizzard lauren
general um Justin like that all I think
he we ended up freelance reviewing that
yeah yeah we like that I'll boy Pete you
liked it a lot pc exclusive know it's
coming to consoles they do have plans
come to console yeah that was also a
while in the making between the art like
just nine years yeah a lot of game this
year 2016 was the game like when people
finally like sat down to finish these
off and you don't refuse them yeah you
did all her or all I mean how many but
yeah boy great great experience for what
you tell us super just awesome
characterization of the world through
music and graphics and animations bring
the characters to life with excellent
writing that reveals new sides of them
that you never really saw coming and you
didn't expect the game to go there in
some ways so another title that Michael
you've been championing for quite a
while I'm glad you're here quickly
quadrilateral cowboy why should we play
it because it's dope art style and
unique gameplay elements uh that's and a
story you can unravel for yourself focus
on hacking to get more real watchdogs
sure with that like jazzpunk kind of
look yeah yeah if you like two guys
summary at all what's not
yeah I like jazzpunk get that cool
people have been kind of uh people a lot
of people i think kind of lamenting the
RTS genre saying it's in decline this
year is actually kind of there are a lot
of RTS releases on PC I mean deserts of
Kharak I played a little bit i loved it
i think that game the story actually
itself it's kind of like i play
starcraft games for the story not the
competition deserts of Kharak if you
want a really good RTS story delve into
that total war war hammer i think it
took what made total war great it made a
few changes to the total war formula
it's we're in a rectangular field if
you're a total war famine what I'm
talking about combine it with warhammer
franchise you know property a lot of
people like that there's Ashley the
singularity which didn't really shape up
but in terms of scale that was really
impressive but in general great year for
the PC library and like I said it's the
year I finally got into building pcs and
whatnot or at least like taking the
first few tentative steps into and kind
of more accessible and VR is a part of
it too yeah I know we talked about VR
distinguisher it but yeah I mean VR pc
is the home of ER cool anyway uh yeah so
Michael hi um your PC report card end of
the year report card will be up on
gamespot if you're not watching this
live you can go read that if you're
watching this live that'll be up in the
next few days we have these coming up in
the next you know coming weeks and yeah
go read that check it out
you